[Música]
hay que dejarse llevar
por esa fuerza que nos hunde
hay que hacernos la vida del tamaño de
nuestra propia ruina
y así será la verdad
porque el veneno será la cura
hay que romper espejos para agrandar la
desdicha
a condición de que no a grande hay que
soltar la voz golpearlo con el presto
látigo de la derrota
hasta aquí a sí mismas inyectó su veneno
la tarea es suave
pero lo suave no se está hablando
cuando pienso en el arte como
resistencia
piensa en lo difícil que ahora es para
todos nosotros
y escuchar
somos una especie
que está lanzada
que nos lanzamos
a llenar el vacío y a saturar nuestros
sentidos
asumimos palabras y más palabras
pensando que en ellas alguien nos va a
decir qué hacer
que alguien nos va a revelar una verdad
y que esa verdad nos va a salvar
no sólo eso consumimos al igual que las
palabras las imágenes ahora en los
dispositivos electrónicos
las palabras y en cuenta imagen
consumimos imágenes y palabras y más
palabras es decir mucha mucha mucha
información
necesitamos llenar huecos
y consumirlo todo
porque si nos sentimos que algo se nos
escapa que algo nos hace falta
los artistas estamos metidos en esa
misma batalla
parece ser que el alto y también ha sido
atrapado con un afán de decir de
defender de hacer discursos de ser el
mejor el más reconocido
es decir lo que nadie ha hecho
por qué
porque será que tenemos esa necesidad
de llenar un vacío que tal vez no existe
y que si existe no va a ser llenado por
una persona que nos diga qué hacer
no va a ser llenado por un discurso tal
vez
probablemente cada vez más nos hemos
vuelto una isla
nos hemos vuelto alguien que está
encerrado en sí mismo y lo único que
importa
es lo que a ti te pasa si lo que tú
piensas
lo que tú sientes lo que tú crees
y mientras eso esté bien no pasa nada
nos cuesta muchísimo trabajo no
sentirnos temerosos tenemos es una
realidad tenemos miedo
aquí tenemos miedo
aquí será que tenemos miedo
igual que yo ahorita tal vez
equivocarnos no
a no hacer para que no vayan a decir
o hacer tan efectivamente que todo mundo
me ponga atención y que nadie tenga
derecho a hacer otra cosa en este mismo
momento
tal vez no debería decir esto pero lo
más interesante no es que yo pueda tener
esta plataforma para hablar
lo interesante sería que todos ustedes
que están ahí sentados también pudieran
pararse aquí no nos llevaría 18 minutos
ni un día tal vez nos llevaría
años
por qué
pues no solamente tendríamos que hablar
sino que tendríamos que hacer lo que
pasa en el silencio
lo que pasa en la incidencia es escuchar
hemos configurado un mundo donde
el poder es algo más allá que nuestra
tienda y que nos dice
como vivir
nos dice que sentir o que se siente que
se piensa que se hace el que se desea
cuando pienso en el arte como
resistencia pienso en que hay un poder a
fidel es
y los buenos francés importantes para el
pensamiento contemporáneo dice que donde
hay miedo
y los artistas tenemos miedo nosotros
tenemos miedo
a fracasar y muchas más cosas
en donde hay miedo hay un poder
un poder que lo cultiva lo cuida
lo haces
y permite que sólo viva viva viva pero
también
en ese lugar donde hay un poder
que cultiva el miedo existe la
posibilidad de resistir
ya no es tan común porque no tenemos ya
ni siquiera ese tipo de iluminarias
los focos son una resistencia
los focos de bombilla antiguos los
ubican
estoy solo aquí
en sus focos lo que tienen adentro es
algo que se llama resistencia
y lo que hace es que deja pasar es decir
si deja que pase algo
pero no cualquier cosa no de cualquier
manera de una muy específica la cantidad
necesaria para que entonces eso ilumine
un poco yo creo que funciona así es
hablando
eso hace que algo ocurra resistir hace
que algo ocurra pero no nos gusta que
ocurra nada nos gusta tener el control
de hecho ese miedo nos ha hecho ser
controladores de todo nos paramos aquí
queremos que todo el mundo piense como
yo pienso nos sentamos allí y nos
importa solo lo que nosotros queremos
que nos importen
difícilmente nos damos cuenta que
podemos escuchar y hacer silencio por
eso creo que una posibilidad de
resistencia hoy en el arte sea eso
les voy a contar dos cosas que me hacen
pensar el arte como resistencia y nada
tienen que ver con los grandes
espectáculos porque es la otra cosa
hemos hecho una vida tan espectacular
que si no es muy espectacular que si yo
no brinco y ya lo fuerte aquí
estuve viviendo en india seis meses
y tuve la oportunidad de ir a un lugar
que se llama darling
está el norte de índia muy cerca de
nepal y el tíbet
y un día caminando entre la neblina
empecé a escuchar unos tambores y unos
cantos lo seguí porque de verdad no se
veía nada llegué
y ese lugar entró sin saber qué pasaba y
una vez allí adentro
veo que hay unos tipos que están con un
tambor en una especie como de alta
budista tal vez no tenía muy claro en
ese momento
un tambor y unos cantos cuando yo entré
no sé de explicarles por qué pero algo
me pasó la piel se me enchinó me dieron
ganas de llorar que no está mal ahora
la tristeza
tampoco era alegría era una conmoción
que no lograba entender
después de un rato me dicen que yo
también puedo tocar un tambor siento y
estoy tratando de hacer su mismo ritmo
salvo
y pregunto bueno y esto qué es
y resulta que sus tipos ahí en lo más
escondido de una montaña en medio de la
neblina sin que nadie los valles los
fotografía y les diga qué bueno son para
el mundo
resulta que hacen eso los 365 días del
año las 24 horas del día todo el tiempo
están cantando y tocando en tambor
la pregunta es por qué
porque es su religión y si no vamos a
hacer esto mientras siga habiendo
violencia en el mundo nosotros no la
vamos a componer el arte no es para
componer una sociedad no se trata de
arreglar nada no se trata de ser
mártires
bien me lo dijo un amigo
se trata de resistir
ellos no quieren cambiar nada ellos sólo
querían resistir
el otro ejemplo para mí todavía más
fuerte
y aquí me hace pensar en algunos alumnos
pequeños que tengo por aquí que acabo de
reconocer
es que había una comunidad de artistas
que fueron a otra comunidad donde había
necesidades especiales y había que
culturizar lo que había que enseñarles
cómo ser grandes artistas para que este
mundo sea mejor y si eso fueron hacer
los artistas y ya fueron los niños y
tomaron taller y allí estaban los
maestros de 100.000 es que para que tú
seas grande tienes que ser así como yo y
tan fatal y nos ponían a hacer pinturas
y esculturas y escribir y acá
había un niño que se mantenía al margen
probablemente la resistencia está en el
margen en los subterráneos se mantenía
al margen iba los escuchaba y se iba
venía otro día iba los escuchaba y se
iban
un día se dieron cuenta que no sólo iba
los escuchaba sino que se metía el salón
y agarra unos materiales dijeron a este
canijo se lo está robando claro pues que
otra cosa vamos a pensar si tenemos
miedo
y resulta que no en el momento lo
siguieron
el niño se iba hasta atrás de todos los
salones y allí atrás había encontrado
una piedra había encontrado un pedazo de
cemento tal vez
y de todo lo que había estado escuchando
que podía ser el arte él había decidido
hacer una cosa con un cincel y con un
pequeño mazo empezar a escribir la
palabra resistir
cuando llegaron los artistas esos
grandes artistas vieron que está pasando
el niño medio que está su historia como
anna regañarle una hora no te preocupes
nada más queremos saber qué está pasando
porque no te acercas con nosotros porque
agarrar existe material y por qué estás
haciendo eso qué estás haciendo
y les dijo es que yo lo único que he
entendido de todo lo que han dicho es
que tal vez es la atención la
posibilidad de yo poder limpiar darle
sentido a mi vida todos los días
y me gustó esa palabra que le hicieron
resistir y entonces este niño iba con un
mazo todos los días a intentar escribir
la palabra
en ese momento dicen los que estaban ahí
me lo contaron a mí se les enchinó la
piel se conmovieron tremendamente porque
alguien sin más pretensión sin más
malicia sin intentar ser el 10 de la
clase de artes entendió que eso podría
ser una acción vital
resistir
no
hay tres tareas tal vez que yo diría que
podríamos hacer para resistir
lo digo como artista pero lo digo como
ser humano también
la primera sería hacer silencio
disfrutar
la otra sería que a partir de ese
silencio
volviéramos a preguntarnos a preguntar a
cuestionar la pregunta no como una ansia
de querer una respuesta
la pregunta como una cuestión como un
camino como algo que puedo mantener
porque es importante la otra sería jugar
pero jugar de una manera específica
jugar de una manera amorosa los niños
juegan este niño que estaba haciendo eso
y con
con la piedra probablemente para él era
un juego pero en un juego vital
en este mundo actualmente pienso yo todo
lo que digo ahora lo pienso pero no lo
pienso como una verdad absoluta
es más fácil estar deprimido resentido
a lo mejor la compañía de psicólogas ya
no espérate pero de alguna manera hay
una zona de confort en eso porque porque
algo más es el culpable de que usted sí
no
el resentimiento
tal vez no sea la manera de resistir
tal vez sea por último el amor el cariño
el afecto el cuidado por el otro
es raro los que me conocen que yo diga
esto pero lo he descubierto
recientemente
el artista que se revela que resiste no
es aquel que reclama que protesta sino
aquel que comprende y abraza tal vez
un querido maestro muy querido maestro
japonés chino japonés porque es de los
dos aunque no lo creo
dijo alguna vez para que el animal
artístico para que la bestia poética sea
libre el ser humano civilizado y
racional tiene que jugar las reglas
tiene que seguir las reglas porque
finalmente el arte es una posibilidad de
posibilidades de libertad
no se trata de negar la regla no se
trata de huir de ella no se trata de
destruir al poder
si no lo jugarán
de conjugar amorosamente
como la agria palomilla que busca
desprenderse de sus alas
la que en la ternura encuentra darlas
para su ojo vivo
una negra canción de cuna
se rumorea en su sangre que arde como
una negra nana espiritual
como las mismas a las de los cuervos
como las llaves de lion como las
irreverentes melodías es un hallazgo
como el filo de un corazón
que no sabe cómo vino al mundo
así entonces en torno a tu garganta
revienta la emoción
y cuando te encuentres cerca
sólo de saludo
que se vaya
que no vuelva
porque el sol así como el amor
amanecer a todos los días es para
nosotros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]